[Music]  movie a big success you got to go to the  premiere okay and i saw this uh  photograph of you is this you with jay  wow what's going on in this photograph  yeah  you really you really did bring the  sound effects yeah i'm actually pointing  to the things that actually made her  famous i couldn't believe that this is  the reason why she was famous famous  yeah and she lets you do that yeah she  lets you just point out her breasts yeah  she's a very very cool person you know  she's there you watch the show jersey  shore at all i don't know checked it out  yeah wow nothing  no no one's admitting it right right  people here are like no  she was there with her boyfriend roger  and they're just both like walking  amazing bodies and all everybody's  thinking is just like wow to watch those  two have sex would be probably amazing  that's what everyone's thinking yes  i actually spoke to everyone